hello everyone i hope you're all having
a wonderful sunday as we are continuing
our saga of the usgs championship where
fabi uh already lost two classical games
and as the highest rated player in the
event has to really really fight to get
back into the race he's um uh trailing
the leaders by a one point margin and
we're gonna see uh can he uh improve on
that as there are still uh three more
rounds to go so here he faces dario
schwercher and it's a really really
incredible game that shows us uh how to
play for the win when you absolutely
have to win uh so uh let's check it out
fabi with the white pieces opens with c4
he goes for the english opening sorry
about that uh and uh we have knight to
f6 by schwerch going for the sort of
anglo-indian defense we have knight to
c3
and e5 now knight f3 knights the c6 and
we have the four knights of the english
we have g3 by fabi preparing to fiance
his light square bishop and bishop to b4
putting pressure on the on the knight
here we have bishop to g2 and now
castles and now knights the d5 an
excellent square for the knight putting
pressure on black's bishop and of course
hoping to
to pick it up uh you can't really trade
here if you trade we simply capture and
then the defender of the e5 pawn is
attacked and if you go for some tricky
lines like knight captures pawn captures
in e4 still not really all that much
we're going to play knight to h4 and
once the knight moves we're going to
pick up the e4 pawn
so black continues as black always does
in this position bishop to c5 and now
how do you play for the win from the
absolute start uh well i'm sure you guys
already know the move uh the usual move
here is just castles and then the game
continues but fabi goes for the absolute
strongest move for white in any position
and that of course is pawn to b4
now offering a pawn attacking the bishop
and well if the bishop moves we might
even attack the knight and remove the
defender of the e5 phone much like one
would for example in the evans gambit so
here black accepts the challenge knight
captures on b4 we have knight captures
and bishop captures and b for knight
captures on e5 winning the pawn back
and now the position has been reached
twice before once in a really notable
game from the 2019 sing field cup
between anish giri and sergey karyakin
where d5 was played by karjakin but here
we have rooked the e8 by scheirche going
after the knight here and it is now only
as of move nine that we have a
completely new game so how does fabi
continue here well you one might expect
something like b3 we defend the knight
and black plays d6 and then the game
continues knight f3 and we got sort of a
uh
well equal-ish position but fabi goes
for knight to d3 uh again puts pressure
on the bishop blocks his own d-pawn and
says nope this knight is coming to f4
and this will be an excellent square for
this knight because you do not have the
e pawn to kick away my knight from f4
and also well i'm definitely not
expecting you to play g5 and open up
your king like this so my knight will be
there for as long as i please so here we
have bishop to a5 also an interesting
retreat is bishop back to f8 but we're
going to discuss this a little bit later
bishop to a5 maybe with ideas of bishop
b6 putting pressure on the king side or
even c6 can be played and then putting
the bishop all the way to c7 so here we
have castles by fabi and c6 now uh e3
and now uh d6 and now finally knight to
f4 the knight is now on an excellent
square the bishop is coming on this long
diagonal and well white's position is
very very enjoyable we have bishop to f5
and now bishop to b2 we have bishop the
e for now hoping to trade off one of um
fabi's strong bishops also an excellent
defender here but fabi says nope i'm
just going to assume control of this
diagonal because your bishop just left
that and you cannot go back with bishop
to f5 so my bishop is very very strong
here i'm going to play d3 kick away your
bishop and then if needed i'm going to
bring my bishop back to this diagonal so
rook to b8 black wants to start pushing
with b5 it would be great if the b uh
file could open up but fabi plays first
d3 chases away the bishop bishop back to
g6 and now bishop the g2 stopping b5 as
then the c6 pawn would fall so bishop
the c7 the bishop really isn't doing all
that much on a5 we have to improve the
position of our pieces and now a4 by
fabi with a6 and now e4
so now we're at move 19 and you can see
uh the position is uh uh well anything
but equal fabi has a monster knight here
he has a monster bishop here uh and it's
just um a heart to to find a reasonable
plan for black there's no move that
seems to be uh improving black's
position so black tries uh executing d5
now this is very dangerous as uh
as you'll see
uh what fabi does so c captures on b5 c
captures on d5 and now sriracha is
saying okay if you want to pick up this
pawn you have to give up your monster
bishop for my knight here and then
you're welcome to pick up the pawn but
fabi says all right that's exactly what
i'm gonna do so he plays bishop captures
on f6 queen captures and now knight
captures on d5 attacking the queen and
the bishop so the queen has to go back
to defend the bishop uh you can do it
via queen to d6 or queen to d8 queen to
d8 is what was played and now h4 by fabi
preparing h5 this will kick away the
bishop and then you might consider some
queen to g4 ideas maybe knight to f4 in
the future and putting some pressure on
the black king uh and here you could
play h6 uh to kind of make room for a
bishop on h7 but swear to plays f6
instead he wants to make room on his
bishop on
f7 or if the rook moves even on the e8
square
and now
we have rook to c1
uh going uh
uh going after the bishop here so the
bishop is now attacked twice we have
bishop to d6 and now knight back to e3
this is what we wanted we want to play
queen to g for push h5 push h6 maybe
bring the knight to f5 and put some
pressure on the black king like this so
b5 schweitz says all right i'm going to
have to
play on the queen side you are obviously
stronger on the king side i'm going to
create a pass pawn here and push it to
victory hopefully so fabi captures we
have a captures on b5 and now queen to
g4 so preparing this uh h5 move so
bishop back to f8 remember when we said
in the beginning of the game that the
bishop might be better suited on f8 well
it found its way there uh you know
regardless so rook after d1 we have to
defend our pawn and also we might
consider also pushing those pawns and
now b4 by black we have d4 by fabi and
b3 now so this is now a really really
dangerous pass pawn but luckily the e4
pawn stops this bishop from guarding b1
so after b2 we can always play something
like rook to b1
uh h5 by fabi bishop back to f7 instead
of bishop to f7 you could play a b2
right away of course and after rook to
b1 then move the bishop but it doesn't
seem to be giving black anything so
instead bishop back to f7 and now fabi
plays d5 cut off the bishop again and uh
well we simply don't care about this
pawn if uh
uh or rather you should care about this
pawn but
only if black acts accordingly right
away for example if b2 rook b1 now the
rook left the c file and we can play
queen to c8 and this is how we slow down
white's attack the queen now has the
movie can't really remain there and
after some like queen to e2 we just
continue playing the game we can even
activate further with queen to c8 uh and
maybe somehow get our bishop pair active
maybe something like queen to c3 bring
the bishop to c5 put pressure here so
there are options here however black
played king to h8 and this gives fabi
just enough time he plays rook to b1 uh
and now again if queen to see it we're
just gonna move the queen but it's uh
it's a little bit different now black
plays uh bishop the c5 of course he
would very much enjoy capturing this
knight fobby just brings it to f5 but
now what black did is uh he freed the g8
square for his rook so rook the g8 now
guards against checkmate here uh but the
problem is you always have to be careful
when boxing your king in like this
because it's somewhat easy to take
advantage of it
and here you should play h6 it seems um
counterintuitive because you open up the
g file for the black rook but here h6
really does a lot for white and now if g
captures on h6 uh if g5 or something
like this you don't really care you're
gonna have an output on g7 for your
knight the the idea is capturus attacks
the queen and queen back to f3 and now
you're gonna either pick up the b3 pawn
or you're gonna pick up the h6 pawn
attacking the rook and the bishop here
so white is really really just enjoying
this position
but fabi said maybe i don't have to play
this right away i'm gonna play queen to
f3 put pressure on the b3 pawn and then
i'm gonna play h6 so it's pretty much
the same thing
but it looks kind of safer
the problem is black has uh
such a
brilliant maneuver here that uh could uh
you know definitely punish fob before
for not going h6 right away but it's
really really difficult to spot like
really difficult i i even feel bad
you know for asking you to try and do
this on a sunday but still feel free to
pause the video here and find this
incredible idea for black while i give
you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting this
incredible defensive resource and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is bishop captures on h5 that's
the good stuff that's why the pawn had
to be pushed to h6 right away and did
not allow this uh
incredible resource uh from black this
was not played in the game this is just
something that was in the position but
it's uh hard to spot and now the thing
is if queen captures we just play g6 and
we don't care we're gonna capture the
knight and the white is still okay but
you know giving up the the knight like
this maybe not uh the way to go so what
white would probably do here if bishop
captures his play g4 push back the
bishop but the problem is after bishop
the e8 now you have problems of picking
up the b3 pawn if rook captures b3 we're
gonna play bishop to a4 and now
everything just gets traded down rook
characters queen captures uh your your
rook is under attack our bishop's pair
has been activated and the attack is uh
well
almost but gone but black has very firm
control of the position and the queen
controls the dark squares here if the
bishop goes here then the pawns will
never be able to advance over those dark
squares so it would be a brilliant way
of defending however black missed this
bishop captures an h5 idea he played
rook to b4 he does uh the exact same
mistake fabi made he said uh yeah i can
do this uh later on uh but uh he can't
really here um
[Music]
the problem is he's trying to trick fabi
he wants fabi to play rook captures on
b3 and then he wants to capture an h5
tricking fabi like this but it's pretty
much doing the same thing fabi did he
thought that he could do it one move
later but he can't now of course the
position would be much better for black
if you pick up the bishop you lose the
rook if you move the queen then you lose
this rook and then this rook
it would be good for black but fabi said
nope i'm not going to capture on b3 i'm
going to play h6 now so it's sort of as
you know during those two moves
both fabi and schwech thought that um
something was possible when in fact it
wasn't so really uh a fun moment um in
chess altogether so here we have g6 uh
not uh really interested in opening up
the g file knight to g7 by fabi and now
b2 yeah so getting rid of this pressure
of rook captures on b3 and now the pawn
on b2 is very dangerous but fabi finds
this incredible e5 move now the d5 pawn
is nicely protected twice you don't have
to worry about that and now what do you
do about this there's not much you can
do you can't capture the bishop on f7
hangs so here we have bishop to d4 uh
and now fabi advances the pawn all the
way we have e6 chasing the bishop bank
bishop to e8 and now
this piece is doing nothing this piece
is doing nothing the queen really not
doing all that much so the only active
piece is this bishop here which is
really controlling a lot so we're just
going to eliminate it this is what fabi
does rook captures on the four rook
captures and rook captures on b2 getting
that uh beautiful past b pawn as well
and now uh you don't really have uh
an active move here for black here tries
uh bishop to a4 of course you gain some
control over the d1 square but the king
will be very safe on h2 and also it's
very hard to activate your pieces here
the queen can't move you have to keep an
eye on f6 the rook doesn't really have
anywhere to go so rook to b7 a very nice
rook lift by fabi and now comes f5 so
what can you play here well fabi goes
for the uh quickest way possible not the
quickest the quickest way is actually
even more interesting fabi goes for
knight captures on f5 and it's a
beautiful move knight the h5 was even
faster because now
uh there is not all that much you can do
queen to c3 is coming with with a
terrible threat but also if the knight
is captured then just queen captures on
f5 you can't stop checkmate there's no
defense here for black fobby plays a
similar line he plays knight captures on
f5 and now what do you do the rook is
attacked if the knight is captured it's
the same thing queen uh will deliver
checkmate this is unstoppable so
tries rook to d1 check as we said the
bishop nicely defends drug but after
king h2 there is not all that much you
can play here queen the f6 now hoping
that if the knight moves at least we can
trade queens and maybe continue playing
this but fabi just placed knight to d6
and he was in this position on move 44
that darius
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here uh the problem is
uh your queen is attacked uh if you move
the queen the knight f7 is just
checkmate the pawn covers the g7 square
there's no stopping that and if you
trade queens it's not much better uh
just to give you an example bishop
captures an f3 attacks the rook and d1
of course we have to move this rook uh
but where where do we move it
it's a
very very uh tricky tricky question uh
because if we move the rook let's say
rook to a1 just knight to f7 again with
checkmate so we have to play something
like rook to a8 allow our king the g8
square to escape now we pick up the rook
and after bishop captures on d1 of
course this end game is completely
winning for those of you who really
enjoy when i finish the game so we can
push e7 and after bishop to a4
controlling some light squares here
we're gonna play knight to e4 make room
for this pawn to start advancing forward
and black is without moves the d7 square
is protected we're gonna play d6 d7 and
that's it whatever black plays d6
doesn't really matter king g8 we're
gonna play knight g5 take away the f7
square from the black king bishop to c6
but now we still don't care just d7 and
that's it uh we're either capturing here
or if bishop captures so we simply play
rook captures and d7 and now the black
is without moves you have to play
something rook to d8 and that's it
whatever you play we can even bring a
rook into the game to deliver checkmate
as our good friend the pawn here
guards the g7 square
so really really an impressive game and
it really shows you how to play for the
win when you absolutely must win and
this is uh definitely the position fabi
found himself in after losing two
classical games not one but two uh which
is for him incredible i i i can't say i
remember last time he lost two games in
a row uh in a in a classical tournament
uh but yeah here just uh incredible
stuff in this position after bishop the
c5 just going for the kill right away
with b4 it's such a such an impressive
idea uh but like i said
it's a known position but the b4 only
played two times here so this is uh how
deep uh fobby dug in to you know create
some winning chances in this game
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it and that it improved your
sunday at least a little bit what does
this mean for the standings well the
leaders are still as they were lenderman
savion and wesley so but fabi now
trailing by half a point so we'll see if
he manages to do it and in the final two
rounds fabi will uh face slenderman who
is one of the leaders and wesley will
face samuel savion who is also one of
the leaders so it's basically if fabi
does incredibly well uh the only one who
could stop him is wesley so but both
lenderman and savion have been playing
an incredible tournament so of course we
are expecting them to
finish strong
in the last two games as well
so that's the game and a little update
about the the standings hope you guys
enjoyed that uh i would like to thank
nikola staksidis david kimura john
cousins and prashant ravat for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it and also abcs
of chess for kids uh who says that um
the book abc's for chess for kids is
absolutely free for download on kindle
today and tomorrow so on the
17th and 18th of october
so yeah
i hope you guys enjoyed that as usual
you can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon uh checking up on the usgs
championship also of course on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world so thank you
all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your sunday